does it make you sad
that people might use
increasingly used chat GPT for something
where they would previously use
Wikipedia so basically
use it to answer basic questions about
the Eiffel Tower
yeah and where the answer really comes
at the source of it from Wikipedia but
they're using this as an interface yeah
no no that's completely fine I mean part
of it is our ethos has always been
here's our gift of the world make
something so if the knowledge is more
accessible to people even if they're not
coming through us that's fine now
obviously we do have certain business
model concerns right like if and we've
talked where we've had more conversation
about this this whole GPT thing is new
things like if you ask Alexa
um you know what what is the Eiffel
Tower and she reads you the first two
sentences from Wikipedia and doesn't say
it's from Wikipedia and they've recently
started citing Wikipedia then we worry
like oh if people don't know they're
getting the knowledge from us are they
going to donate money are they just
thinking oh what's Wikipedia for I can
just ask Alexa it's like well Alex only
knows anything because she read
Wikipedia so we do think about that but
it doesn't bother me in the sense of
like oh I want people always come to
Wikipedia first but we're also you know
it had a great demo like literally just
hacked together over a weekend by our
head of machine learning
where he did this little thing to say
um you could ask any question and he was
just knocking it together so he used uh
the open ai's API just to make a demo
ask a question
um why do ducks fly South for winter
which is the kind of thing you think oh
I I might just Google for that I might
start looking in Wikipedia I don't know
and so what he did is he asks judge me
what are some Wikipedia entries that
might answer this then he grabbed those
Wikipedia entries
said here's some Wikipedia entries
answer this question based only on the
information in this and he had pretty
good results and it kind of prevented
the making stuff up not it's just a he
hacked together a weekend but what it
made me think about was
okay so now we've got this huge body of
knowledge
that in many cases you're like oh I'm
really I want to know about Queen
Victoria I'm just going to go read the
Wikipedia entry and it's going to take
me through
her life and and so forth but other
times you've got a specific question and
maybe we could have a better search
experience where you can come to
Wikipedia ask your specific question get
your specific answer that's from
Wikipedia including links to the
Articles you might want to read next and
that's just a step forward like that's
just using a new type of technology to
make the extraction of information from
this body of text into my brain
faster and easier so I think that's kind
of cool I I would love to see a Chad GPT
grounding into websites like Wikipedia
and the other comparable website to me
will be like wolf from Alpha for more
mathematical knowledge that kind of
stuff so grounding like taking you to a
page that is really crafted as opposed
to like the moment you start actually
taking you to like journalist websites
like uh news websites it starts getting
a little iffy yeah it's getting a little
yeah yeah yeah because they have you're
now in a land that has a wrong incentive
right yeah you pulled in and you need
somebody to have filtered through that
and sort of tried to knock off the rough
edges yeah no it's it's very uh I think
that's exactly right and I think
um
you know I I think that kind of
grounding is I think they're working
really hard on it I think that's really
important and that actually when I so if
we if you asked me to step back and be
like very business-like about our
business model and where is it going to
go for us and are we going to lose half
our donations because everybody's just
going to stop coming to Wikipedia and go
to charge gbt I think well grounding
will help a lot because
frankly most questions people have if
they provide proper links we're going to
be at the top of that just like we are
in Google so we're still going to get
tons of recognition and tons of of
traffic just from even if it's just the
moral
properness of saying here's my source
um so I think I think we're going to be
all right in that in that yeah in the
close Partnership of if the model is
fine-tuned is constantly retrained that
Wikipedia is one of the primary places
where if you want to change what the
model knows one of the things you should
do is contribute to a Wikipedia or
clarifying Wikipedia yeah yeah or
elaborate expand all that kind of stuff
yeah